usually when we think of world building
in a film we imagine shots like these
sweeping wides that establish
architecture and environments or
interesting exposition about the world's
technology only the native tribes known
as the freyman have adapted well enough
to survive
but dune places just as much emphasis on
another kind of world building by
establishing many scenes with sensory
details from the world instead of wide
shots of locations the film places
special emphasis on what the world of
dune feels like
i would call it brain stemi images
it's appealing to some part of the brain
that's old and not necessarily verbal
and they're all very sensory incredibly
sensory that's joe walker and he's not
just the voice of the dictionary in dune
he's also the film's editor walker and
director denny valeneuv have a
well-established partnership and they
have done a lot of amazing work together
but when they tackled dune they took on
a unique challenge
dune is a massive book with tons of
characters lots of interesting details
worlds factions and ideas to establish
before you can even tell the story so
editor joe walker was going to need to
adopt a slightly less conventional
approach to editing to accomplish
everything he needed to on screen
i'm sure most of you are familiar with
the idea of continuity
continuity of action is when the action
of a scene seems to continue smoothly
from one shot to the next
for example if we look carefully at a
moment from the training scene we can
see how an action that starts in this
shot continues smoothly into this shot
most scenes from most movies you watch
broadly try to respect or maintain a
sense of continuity of action within a
scene but in this moment from dune
walker breaks continuity
you can see how the action of this shot
and the following two shots don't align
the action does not continue from one
shot to the next in this moment walker
is breaking continuity of action to
signal something important to the viewer
paul is using the voice to try to
influence the lady jessica's action but
he fails the action signified in this
shot only takes place in lady jessica's
mind not in reality and the break in
continuity helps illustrate that it's a
clever trick that communicates the idea
of what's happening very intuitively and
effectively to the viewer and walker is
setting this up as a piece of editing
grammar that he can use again in the
future to illustrate the use of the
voice this kind of creative use of
editing to get concepts across visually
is necessary to effectively adapt for
screen such a complex and detailed book
i think a very typical cinematic thing
is
simplicity
and economy
and we're looking we were looking for
that in the cart but also paying you
know our dues to the book and also to
the depth of that imagination
that frank herbert originally had look
at how at the beginning of the john
gabar scene there's a shot where paul
comes to a stop then another shot where
he seems to walk forward as the reverend
mother speaks
but when it cuts back to paul we can see
that he's still standing in the same
spot he was when she actually uses the
voice moments later there is another
break in continuity
but this time the action is not reset
back in time once walker establishes
these breaks in continuity he doesn't
just use them to signal the voice he
also uses them to indicate when
something more metaphysical is happening
in the film for example here during the
spice mining scene when paul is hit by a
wave of spice in the desert walker uses
a jump cut between two similar images
with a shift in focus to help indicate
that something strange is happening it's
visually very similar to when the
reverend mother uses the voice on paul
while the use of the voice and the
visions aren't exactly the same thing in
the world of doom they're both tapping
into the world's metaphysical elements
so it makes sense to use a similar
visual language for both
this close-up of paul that comes
immediately before this breaking
continuity is also very important as
part of a visual motif that walker uses
at the start of paul's visions look at
all the shots that precede paul's
visions this motif of subjective
close-ups places us in paul's
perspective and helps establish the
visions
but in this specific case it signals
that a vision is happening even though
we don't actually see the vision until
later actually showing the vision here
would break up the suspense and action
of this scene so walker uses this visual
motif as an indicator to the viewer of
what's happening and then later he
establishes a flashback to the vision
what did you see
by returning to that same shot
and so we'd understand visually the
movement and time here to when the
flashback is taking place even if we
didn't have the dialogue of this scene
these noticeable breaks in continuity of
action help signal to us that something
unusual or unnatural is happening but
dune is actually full of many breaks and
continuity of action that we don't
notice because the main driving force of
the film i'd like to argue is not
continuity of action but a different
kind of continuity june if nothing else
is for me one massive
work of rhythm
you're probably familiar with the term
montage the popular use of the term
refers to what we call montages or
scenes that consist of a collection of
shots that are usually disconnected in
time placed together in a rhythm and
usually set to music traditional montage
technique plays an important role in
dune walker uses them to powerful effect
to illustrate paul's visions but the
montage approach to editing can also be
used for scenes that we wouldn't
traditionally think about as a montage
in this scene each shot is a contained
unit of action and while they combine to
create an impression of continuing
action the action doesn't actually
continue fluidly from one shot to the
next
it feels cohesive but see how in this
shot they're hammering the stakes in
this shot they're pulling down the tarp
and in this shot the ropes are already
wrapped around the stakes there's a
significant jump in time between each
shot here we're not seeing the thopter
being covered as a continuous action
we're seeing a montage of the thopter
being covered so why do these brakes and
continuity jump out at us while we don't
notice these well while these shots do
break continuity of action in the
montage mode they follow a different
type of continuity there's still a
continuity between the shots but instead
of continuity of action it's a
continuity of information of emotion and
of rhythm you know my background's in
music and you're a composer there's a
lot of similarities but the main thing
is pace and rhythm
[Music]
to understand how continuity of emotion
and information works let's look at the
leaving kaladan montage and examine what
each shot or block of shots represents
informationally and emotionally the
first four images are of the ships
rising out of water paul picking some
grass and paul watching the ships rising
out of the water informationally we're
seeing the atreides are preparing to
leave and the water and the grass are
emphasized which stand in contrast to
the environment of arrakis emotionally
we get the idea of paul's connection to
the environment and his contemplation of
leaving his home planet then we get two
shots of packing there's really no clear
continuity of action location or time
between these two shots and the first
four but these two shots are connected
to the concept of leaving that has
already been established in the first
four shots this is what i mean by
continuity of information then we get a
shot of duke leto's hand comforting lady
jessica and we instantly can recognize
this as an action that's most likely
responding to her nervousness about
leaving this connects emotionally to the
earlier shot where paul is contemplating
leaving this is what i mean by
continuity of emotion
then the montage cuts back to paul in a
new location but informational
continuity is maintained because we can
see the ships are higher in the sky and
the departure is progressing and there's
this shot of paul's hand in the water
maintaining the informational continuity
with the earlier shot of the grass and
the emotional continuity with the idea
of paul's connection to the environment
and finally we get a shot that seems to
convey paul trying to feel determined in
the face of the unknown which has a
strong emotional continuity to this shot
so even though these shots are
dramatically disconnected in time and
space it all feels cohesive because we
can easily follow an emotional and
informational narrative that's unfolding
i want to be clear this doesn't mean the
audience is consciously thinking about
what each shot means the power of images
is that they can communicate what i just
broke down with words a lot faster than
i can because they're doing it on an
intuitive non-verbal level the brain
stemming images that walker talked about
aren't just great ways to establish a
scene they're also powerful tools within
montage to communicate complex emotional
ideas on a non-verbal level there's no
handbook or formula you can follow here
while continuity of action has a clear
physical logic continuity of emotion and
information don't you just have to
develop a sense of what the audience
will be feeling as they watch i think
the most important thing an editor does
is has an imaginary audience
over his or her back you're probably
picking up on the fact that the
distinction between the montage mode of
editing and continuity editing is not a
clear binary and sometimes the line
between the two modes gets pretty fuzzy
you can even have a sequence that acts
as a montage of many scenes with
continuity of action mixed together with
individual shots that are out of
continuity as long as you respect the
continuity of rhythm emotion and
information it will make sense to the
audience an example of a scene that
exists in this middle space is the john
gabar scene
here except when the voice is used the
action of the scene maintains physical
continuity of action but there are shots
that interject that align with
continuity of information and emotion
that tell us a story about what paul is
experiencing subjectively but the main
reason these shots actually work in this
scene is because the driving force of
the moment is actually continuity of
rhythm the music performances editing
and sound design are all working
together to build towards a climax
enough
so that rhythm could be
you know the sound of a thumper or it
could be
the raising of an eyebrow by stephen
mckinley henderson
rhythm in film is most obviously created
in this way by using sound design score
and the rhythm of the actual cuts
themselves but how is rhythm created by
the raising of an eyebrow when you turn
the sound off you become hyper aware of
people's eyes and i feel like eyes
that's a serious part of what we do is
like driving the cup by the expression
in the eyes the timing of an action
within a shot and the distance between
the end of an action and a cut create a
rhythm and pace for each shot look at
this three-shot sequence do not
trespass in our lands
the desert was ours long before you came
it feels fluid and seamless but watch
again if i adjust the shot of paul by
removing only a few frames do not
trespass in our lands the desert was
ours long before you came it's a more
jarring cut because i'm cutting too
close to the movement of paul's eyes
it's easy to miss so here's the original
the desert was ours long before you came
and here's my botched cut again the
desert was ours long before you came
this tiny adjustment breaks the
continuity of the rhythm of the scene
it's almost imperceptible but there's a
rhythm to this shot the time between the
cut and when paul starts moving his eyes
is a beat while paul is moving his eyes
is a beat and then again between the end
of the action of his eyes moving and the
next cut is a final beat and when we cut
in such a way that breaks the rhythm of
that action with the cuts it feels more
jarring one little cut that's off like
this doesn't feel like a big deal but if
you pile up enough of these within a
scene the continuity of rhythm is
destroyed this scene isn't even a
montage and continuity of rhythm still
matters if you're jumping around in time
and space continuity of rhythm becomes
even more important what's incredible
here to me is that even with the
strength of zimmer score walker doesn't
just sit back and let it do all the
heavy lifting to research this video i
watch dune entirely without sound and it
has a strong visual rhythm and flow even
without the rhythm of the sound pulling
that off requires an incredible
attention to detail and a strong
intuitive sense of what works
emotionally and rhythmically the best
way to develop that intuition as an
editor is to watch lots of great films
practice editing yourself and to listen
to the perspective of experienced
editors who do quality work for a long
time the art of the cup podcast series
has been one of my favorite resources
for in-depth interviews with some of the
greatest editors in film and tv so i was
very excited to see that the frame is
insider was bringing the art of the cut
in video form to youtube i've been
enjoying the art of the cut interviews
for years and i've learned so much about
editing from these interviews people
often ask me where i've learned what i
know about film and honestly i've
learned most of it from filmmakers
themselves in interviews and behind the
scenes content like art of the cut so if
you enjoyed my breakdown of dune joe
walker goes into a lot more detail in
the full interview you're trying always
as an editor to be
in parallel or ahead of the audience
slightly ahead not too far ahead and
never behind right if you're behind
you're dead i highly recommend watching
the rest of the interview and
subscribing over there so you can watch
more episodes click the link in the
description to subscribe to the podcast
or click the link on the screen to watch
the video now and thank you so much to
the frame isle insider for sponsoring
this video and making it possible the
frame io insider is a fantastic
filmmaking blog with in-depth guides
articles and tutorials for experienced
and aspiring editors producers
cinematographers colorists and anyone
who's interested in filmmaking